[MUSIC PLAYING]
So there's an
amazing philosopher
called Eliade, who wrote a
book about shamanism, where
he spoke of psychedelic drugs
as technologies of ecstasy.
Notice that he uses the
term "technologies" here.
He talks about them as
mankind's cognitive toolkit,
agents of psychic
transformation.
We've been engaging for
tens of thousands of years
to transform the perceptions
of the body, mind.
Hacking our awareness
and our perceptions,
you know that effervescent flux
of sensation and perception
that is in a way of
all we have and all
we are, as Erik Davis says.
The voice in your head that
lets you know you exist.
These psychedelic agents,
these "meme" mutagens
essentially cause mutation
and ideation in our ideas.
And I think that term
"technologies of ecstasy"
points to the fact
that there is something
that happens in that ecstatic
place of ego death that resets
the self, that gives us
temporarily access, that makes
us privy to a whole host
of new, wild visions
that transform the
way we see the world.
And I think today, these modern
digital shamans, these ecstatic
technicians of the sacred,
these doctors of the word,
are the scientists and
philosophers and writers
that are there making us
question our current belief
systems and decoditioning
our thinking,
and that has always been
the role of the shaman
to unplug us and show us
the bigger, wider, more
far reaching universe that goes
beyond what the eye can see.
Or something like that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]